le secrétaire général de l'OTAN Yann
toltenberg a souligné hier que la Russie
était entrée en guerre contre l'Ukraine
avec l'objectif d'avoir moins de temps
mais que finalement c'était le contraire
qui était en train de se passer et c'est
vrai que l'adhésion de la Finlande
représente une évolution stratégique
importante pour l'OTAN qui double sa
frontière avec la Russie puisque la
Finlande partage 1300 km de frontière
avec la Russie et c'est donc un moyen de
renforcer son flanc nord-est ou les pays
baltes étaient finalement en position de
faiblesse entre l'enclave russe de
Kaliningrad la Biélorussie et la Russie
et puis avec l'adhésion de la Finlande
l'OTAN
hérite d'une armée puissante puisque
même si la Finlande appliquait une
politique de non-alignement militaire
elle n'a jamais baissé la garde face à
son grand voisin russe et contrairement
à certains pays de l'OTAN elle a
maintenu son service militaire par
exemple et puis elle dispose d'une des
artillerie les plus fournies de l'Union
européenne avec 1500 pièces à l'heure de
côté la Russie à d'ores et déjà prévenu
qu'elle allait renforcer ses capacités
militaires à la frontière finlandaise et
elle a également prévenu que si des
forces venant d'autres pays de l'OTAN
venaient à se déployer enfin l'angle
elle prendrait des mesures
supplémentaires